so good afternoon to all of you it's
wonderful to have you
I am absolutely delighted to have the
opportunity to announce a third and
final castle lecture of 2019 so I
realized you were all now familiar with
the origin and the format but I just
want to say especially how grateful we
are to John castle for endowing these
lectures in honor of his ancestor one of
the ales founders John Pierpont it was
mr. castles intention to create a forum
for exploring large topics and powerful
ideas and we are so delighted to have
just as Cuellar as a person who embodies
that spirit so by now you all know a
fair amount about justice Cuellar you
know that he serves as a justice on the
Supreme Court of California you know
that he previously served as the Stanley
Morison professor of law at Stanford and
in many roles in the Obama
administration I just want to say he is
a beloved figure among our alumni and a
much admired one that doesn't really is
not really a fair thing to say but as
Dean I want to claim him he's a beloved
and admired figure in the entire legal
profession so he belongs to all of us I
think part of what makes these lectures
so compelling is the way that they allow
us to keep returning to the same subject
over time and to do it over a series of
days rather than all at once and since
you've heard the first two lectures I
know you can appreciate the importance
of the questions that he's raising today
and why they require our sustained
attention I mean there's a reason why we
as pedagogue pedagogical masters try to
space courses out over a full semester
we can tell you that any time you meet
learn something you need to return to it
and rethink it and look at it from a
different lens and that's sort of the
magic of these lectures and what makes
them really distinctive and special this
is my pleasure to reintroduce professor
Cuellar whose own life I think is a
testimony to the values of seeing this
country from all of its many sides his
life has been defined and I think his
work has been powerfully informed by
perpetual change of perspective he was
born in Mexico as a boy he crossed the
border five times a week to go to junior
high in Brownsville Texas he'd said at
one point that this gave him the sense
that he inhabited two worlds and at 14
when his family moved to California he
entered a completely new school in the
middle of his high school years and of
course
we no no he excelled there and rolling
is an undergraduate harvard becoming for
coming here to yale law school and then
returning to California for his PhD the
ëthe of working across boundaries I
think has defined his career ever since
and I know you're thinking there's a
really big boundary in his background
which is going from Harvard to Yale
we're delighted that he decided to come
a little south and depart from that
rather unknown place up north but in all
seriousness I actually think that much
of his career is about helping others to
think about how to cross boundaries as
well his career has always tacked
between practice and the Academy even as
a law student he launched a non-profit
focused on teaching English and he spent
summers working to advocate for policy
change including the repeal of Don't Ask
Don't Tell
after his PhD when he started teaching
at Stanford he took an active role in
staring the university's engagement with
a variety of broader causes and here too
he focused on the law across borders
creating Stanford center for
international law international security
and cooperation and the Freeman spogli
Institute which contains it now what I
like about Teno is that nothing none of
that work ever impeded him from becoming
a great scholar and for producing two
full-length books during that period
he'd entered the lead from Stanford to
join President Obama's Domestic Policy
Council where he led efforts to reform
our criminal justice system and our
immigration system and to improve public
health policy he chaired a commission
that highlighted the substantial
failures of America's public education
system and its failure to close the
achievement gap and do justice by our
country's children and when I think of
him in that role in particular I think
that it was a gift for all of us to have
someone in that position who had seen
America's schools from both sides of the
border who knew why a boy would make a
pilgrimage every day to go to an
American school and just as importantly
what people couldn't or wouldn't do the
same and when I think of him on the
bench I think that actually the highest
calling of the judge maybe this capacity
to see the law in the cases before him
from many sides and we typically in LA
to pick justice as something who was
blindfolded but we all know that no
judge is blindfolded I think the really
the true way to think of what you want
from a judge and the best hope for
judging
a judge's sympathies and vantage points
are the broadest and most capacious in
the room and at the foundation of
justice choirs record for service and
excellence those are the traits that
make him an extraordinary academic an
extraordinary policy maker and an
extraordinary public servant we were
honored to call him a friend of this
university in the school and I am
incredibly delighted to be here to
introduce him for his third and final
lecture please join me in welcoming
Thank You Dean gurken you're a terrific
team the great friend I'm so grateful I
would like to meet the person who just
introduced that I I will tell you you
know one of the greatest gifts of this
opportunity to come back to Yale has
been reconnecting with the time I spent
here I've been back several times before
but something about this trip has been
different part of it is that I have a
wonderful schedule that's been put
together by E P and E but it gave me
some time to walk around to visit the
Orange Street where I used to live and
then to go to counter Street where I
used to live when I go down Whitney
Avenue and I reflect on that all the
more because you gave me a beautiful
gift just a few months ago when I wrote
you out of the blue and asked to see if
you might possibly have a copy of my law
school admissions essay unless I was
scared to write because I was scared
that the answer would be yes all right I
thought that reading the words that one
writes when one is just about to
graduate from college and thinks that
one has figured out the world this very
scary thing but but you didn't have a
copy notwithstanding any number of
document retention policies that
normally make this very unlikely
whenever lawyers are involved and it was
it was refreshing to read it because in
some ways I feel relieved that I have
learned a lot but in other ways I feel
like I'm still much the same person and
and I hope we all can strike that
balance in different ways
so I want to talk to you about a subject
that will relate in both subtle and
maybe more profound ways to the topics
I've discussed in the previous lectures
in the first lecture I kind of started
with a bit of the commencement speech I
gave at Stanford University in 2017
and underscored to you all that I felt
challenged by how optimistic those words
sounded I focused on an incredible
improvements in living standards in
education and clean water that we've all
experienced over the course of 100 years
or most people have experienced in the
world and I wanted to bring back into
the conversation the climate change and
nuclear inequity challenges that the
world faces and to grapple with what
that means for all of us in the second
lecture I talked about how any of us who
have served in government as well as
those of us who have had the privilege
of sticking stepping back and thinking
about how we might do good in the world
the challenges we face being honest with
how complicated it is to answer the
questions of what to do and how to do
that and I talked about how we might do
better in that process today I want to
talk to you about a subject that I could
maybe introduce in different ways but
I'll just start with a brief little
anecdote about a conversation I had with
my daughter so my daughter is in school
and had to read Frankenstein she was
sharing with me how much she loved the
book how compelling it was how complex
she felt it was how it brought to the
fore some ideas about the changing
nature of the world and how the world
deals with mystery and I couldn't help
myself I said I played out in my mind
the conversation I wanted to have with
her I said I wanted to tell her some of
what you find interesting about
Frankenstein is what I find interesting
about the continuing fascination in the
world is beginning to have with
artificial intelligence and how we have
this pull towards it because of a sense
of wonder and its possibilities to solve
problems but some dread and fear about
it as well and isn't that interesting
that you can probably discern that in
Frankenstein that sense of wonder and
possibility at science but also the fear
and the possibility of unexpected
consequences so I broached the subject
with my daughter and I said you know it
reminds me of - you don't say anything
more you're going to tell me that this
is all about artificial intelligence and
I thought to myself I'm gonna ask her am
i that predictable and she said and yes
you are that predictable
so I would like to just hug the problem
actually work big picture first as a
Silicon Valley person I share with you a
country that has been transformed to
some degree by not just the
infrastructure of the internet that was
becoming commercially available right
around the time that I was graduating
from college but by the framework of
technology and knowledge and data and
the infrastructure that does
extraordinary things with that
information that scattered so I would
put it this way it's a our civilizations
achievements include building an
education system that makes education
available on a massive scale improving
public health building a legal system
that can adjudicate even just in my own
state millions of disputes a year
however slowly and imperfectly but among
all these things that we've done one of
the most extraordinary I think is the
ability to build a physical
infrastructure that can perform tasks
that if they were performed by humans
we'd think they require intelligence
from pretty humble origins rooted in the
work of scholars like Allen Newell John
McCarthy Herbert Simon at Fagan Bauman
Barbara grows this field of AI
artificial intelligence has been
transformed by the rise of the Internet
mostly because it's allowed this
unprecedented gathering of data that is
the raw material that this new
technology will not entirely new
technology but this technology newly
uses to do all kinds of interesting
things when it's married up with also
greatly expanded computing power and
I'll say more about that in a moment a
few days ago an academic journal
reported on a survey experiment showing
that automatically generated news
stories evaluated blindly were rated as
more credible and less biased than human
generated ones and there was a
remarkable video you can get on the web
from an outfit in Silicon Valley working
on getting closer to artificial general
intelligence called opening eye and what
they've done is they've used
reinforcement learning to get one robot
hand to solve a Rubik's Cube and it's a
it's a beautiful and eerie thing to see
to be honest just the weird way that it
moves humans can solve Rubik's cubes
with two hands but I
fully difficult you could argue at the
very edge of human ability to do it with
one hand it's always possible though for
reasons I'll explain I think not likely
that humans growing capacity to build
intelligence into physical objects will
plateau or even retreat the two threats
that I'd dwelt on in the first lecture
are for some reasons why nuclear climate
but secular declines in the enthusiasm
for and perceived potential of AI are
quite familiar in the field so it's not
imprudent to think that the rate of
change in the field will go up and down
what I think is striking is that even if
development stops well short of any
breakthrough that makes you know
cross-domain generalized AI loom
anywhere near close
just if you take the technology we have
right now combining software and stand
cheating AI architectures the internet
norms that allow for more centralized
data collection this is all probably
going to have massive effects beyond
what we've seen in our lives so let me
give you just one example to chew on as
I get started so there's a graduating
college senior who wants a job at a
large company very familiar scenario
probably describe some of the undergrads
we're here but first she has to submit
to a video interview on her very own
smartphone through which her facial
expressions the positions of her eyes
her gestures her speech patterns or
copiously analyzed by software
she stole to just be herself to avoid
trying to game the algorithm judging her
performance and as she's interviewed the
algorithm works to assess the fit
between the voluminous data garnered
from the interview all the tight details
it
she can't easily or even at all control
with similar data from employees that
fit the company's definition of
successful what that definition is of
course is up to the company it could be
the genuineness of her warmth in dealing
with a customer the likelihood of her
embrace of the company's culture of
loyalty over a contentious version of
Albert Hirschman voice a few days later
she learns that she's not getting the
job no one explains to her how the
algorithm works nor can she assess the
validity of the predictions made to
think of this scenario as a
science-fiction prediction is of course
wrong eight days ago the Washington Post
wrote about the software and its
extensive use in some companies the
software come
Benny's own CTO defended the product by
emphasizing that quote people are
rejected all the time because of how
they look and algorithms eliminate that
in a way that hasn't been possible
before a scholar from NYU differed
sharply calling the case of the software
pseudoscience and a license to
discriminate and the people whose lives
and opportunities are literally being
shaped by these systems of course don't
have any chance to win that's what she
said now the software is the subject of
a recent complaint before the Federal
Trade Commission and the software will
almost certainly also inspire people the
question in other fora whether cultural
differences in facial expression whether
you spend some time in your childhood in
a public school in another country or
your father's from Kenyan your mother's
from Kansas just to pick two random
places may be driving unacceptably
disparate outcomes of course humans are
not only biased in both quite blunt and
subtle ways we're also prone to anger
and jealousy hunger hangovers that said
comparing software to human deliberation
is complicated human decision makers
must often explain themselves to a
hiring committee or compliance officers
we know what it feels like to be forced
to live with our decisions we may need
to explain them in court or at least to
a compliance officer humans are capable
of empathy with the people they're
interviewing we could ask how these
realities way for or against the use of
such software but the cost-benefit
calculus is a far cry from the
salmonella contamination prevention egg
safety rule that I discussed at the
beginning of my talk yesterday a candid
conversation about such topics
implicates deeper issues about the
blurry line between reasonable behavior
and cognitive error or bias among humans
about the role in our lives of machines
that even the people who design them
don't fully understand about what
determines responsibility between
systems or networks of AI systems and us
about the scope of that conversation as
our society changes and gets used to
autonomous vehicles order systems
coaxing our children to watch videos
they seem powerless to resist
handling these questions rights I would
argue will depend on a mix of humility
and attention the institutional
realities of the kind that I mentioned
in my talk yesterday it will also
require candor about the high stakes of
the conversation about not only
artificial judgment but about human
judgement why is it special for humans
to make decisions why should we defend
that should we but more on this in a
moment in some ways this technology
artificial intelligence scaled up using
the internet is full of possibility for
automatic translation and for
personalized learning for improved
energy efficiency the productivity of
the health sector in particular hasn't
grown in many years but health
employment and cost keep rising as
promised maybe two starkly change that
but will also likely encounter some dark
and difficult subjects weaponized AI
illicit uses elite and masked
disagreement about its proper role
dislocation of workers and cultural
conflict because the terrain gets more
uneven and Messier it's probably worth
approaching our deepening engagement
with AI with some of the wisdom gleaned
from our relationship to the problems I
discussed in my first lecture climate
change and nuclear the underlying
technologies may be different but the
capacity of society to take a technology
fertile with possibility to an illogical
or at least dangerous extreme should be
self-evident and it's better taken
seriously instead of being ignored
so the reflections that follow began
from that premise and also try to take
seriously the difficulties of weighing
consequences that I surveyed in the
lecture yesterday some of those
difficulties are made all the more
interesting because of course the
technology is becoming more capable of
shaping not only our physical
environment but our preferences and
values rather than just the details of
our surroundings I'll review some of the
drivers of recent interest in and then
consider some of the opportunities and
risks I'll make a very tentative case
for the importance of human judgment at
least in consequential personal or
social decision-making in a world that
will increasingly want to rely on AI for
a routine decision-making then I'll
sketch out some broader themes that I
hope will connect all three lectures a
little
but okay the changing path and
development of AI the air systems are
used not only in hiring but in pre-trial
risk assessment they inform medical
diagnosis they power global networks of
content and data that interact with
billions of users and are increasingly
at the core of global commerce for
anyone in my profession who rightly
worries about access to justice for
hundreds of millions of Americans and
frankly billions around the world it
should be clear that properly designed
AI systems have the potential to enhance
access to justice through automated
analysis of legal claims and provision
of assistance perhaps even in real time
even just in California millions of
litigants who currently seek to navigate
the court system without a lawyer flail
and struggle and have difficulty I would
like them all to have a lawyer in person
but that's not likely to happen in my
lifetime where in my kids lifetime and
all of this may just be the beginning of
far more fundamental transformations
that can be affected by a ia and impact
for good or nots millions of jobs and
will engage lots and lots of people in
new social arrangements new kinds of
relationships new forms of entertainment
as many of you know the cutting edge of
worked in advanced AI relies on
artificial neural networks somewhat
loosely inspired on the architecture of
the human brain they deploy a panoply of
layers and sometimes millions of
variables to spot patterns a few
discernible trends to my mind are
apparent in the work of the
organizations that are most dedicated to
advancing the cutting edge here which I
defined by efforts that are credible to
pursue generalized AI that can have a
degree of intelligence that cuts across
different contexts using techniques such
as deep reinforcement learning these AI
systems are capable of increasingly
complex behavior even if it's daunting
or worse
to understand or explain exactly how
they work the one-handed robot I
mentioned less dexterous than a human
can now solve a rubik's cube using
reinforcement learning so millions of
trials that are constantly updating and
teaching the system how the world might
be made to work better the way the
system needs it to work so that it can
solve the
also worth observing in addition to you
know the beating of humans and strategy
games like go or Starcraft including the
very best humans is how techniques to
understand and generate language have
improved pretty starkly in just the last
six months one system for instance an
open AI does a reasonable job of
generating whole stories from simple
prompts by using a vast store of mostly
internet scraped text data to generate
fairly convincing narratives these
advances reflect something of a
breakdown in what we call Moore's Law
the notion that computing power would
improve and essentially double over the
course of a two-year cycle but the rate
that of Moore's law is in precisely the
opposite direction that I would hear
people talk about five years ago which
is it's gonna break down and those
increases in computing power are going
to peter out instead what is a better
description of what's going on given the
heavy reliance on new processor designs
and also the availability of new
computing power to do these tasks is
that the computing capacity being made
available to AI system seems to be
doubling at a rate of about every three
and a half months by one credible
estimate as companies and researchers
have come to rely on artificial neural
networks to discern patterns and massive
amounts of data we've come to understand
even more clearly one important feature
of intelligence some of what seems to
depend on cognition like translating
languages or optimizing the persuasive
appeal of an ad actually involves the
kind of recognition more akin to the
flash of insight when a person matches a
situation and a learned response it's
worth remembering that this insight is
far from entirely new even if the
staggering amounts of data and computing
power give it more currency and open up
new ways to use the insight but here's a
little reality check about how what's
new is nuts on you here's one of you
know the people I most admire in this
field Herbert Simon talking 62 years ago
delivering a key insight with his
trademark pettiness this is what he said
a large part of the difference between
the experienced decision maker and the
novice is not any particular intangible
like judgment
intuition if one could open the lid so
to speak and see what was in the head of
the experienced decision-maker one would
find that he had he sick at his disposal
repertoires of possible actions and that
he had checklists of things to think
about before he acted and that he had
mechanisms in his mind to evoke these
and bring to his conscious attention
when the situations for decision arose
evoked quickly at the time of decision
while there's no guarantee that these
trends will continue I suspect the use
of alphabet deep Minds AI technology to
optimize energy use in Google's server
farms which is happening is a harbinger
of things to come where the most
advanced AI begins to be used to enhance
the functions of AI itself and it's
worth remembering how often predictions
making technological progress seem quite
remote turn out to be wrong as Eleazar
you louse key points out in a 2017 paper
and I quote in 1901 two years before
helping build the first heavier-than-air
flier Wilbur Wright told his brother
powered flight was fifty years away in
1939 three years before he personally
oversaw the first critical chain
reaction in uranium bricks Enrico Fermi
voiced 90% confidence that was
impossible to use uranium to sustain a
fission chain reaction if Fermi and
Wright couldn't see those inflection
points just around the corner
think of how daunting it was for anyone
else at the time who lacked their
expertise and their underlying
infrastructure wasn't W capacity every
3.5 months sure it's difficult to know
how to forge some kind of generalized
intelligence maybe we'll never get there
or whether nothing but brute force
computing power and ever more elaborate
neural networks will do most of the work
I doubt it'll be that simple
I suspect the architecture will have to
change and we'll have to do more than
pattern recognition we'll have to rely
on representations of knowledge and
symbolic logic as well but there's also
you know other impediments to I'd
mentioned which is we don't yet fully
understand how humans biological
Hardware facilitate a degree of
computation and a different form of
intelligence perhaps in
were able to build but all that said it
seems to me quite a remote possibility
that the best bet to make is that this
technology it's not really going to
change that much and not going to
improve so let me now talk about risks
and challenges that accompany the
opportunity bias and discrimination is
one example of the risks that people
readily recognize but that's not the
only thing we can talk about we can talk
about systemic failure we can talk about
the risk of emergent properties with
larger scale and even existential
consequences for society as some of the
machines that we designed turned out not
to behave in the way so we expect at all
perhaps not surprisingly professor
Steven Pinker whom I mentioned in my
Tuesday lecture has a view about this he
quite doubts the likelihood that serious
long-term consequences serious long-term
concerns about AI are warranted
let me quote him for just a moment I
think all this fear of AI is nonsensical
and based on two internally self
contradictory premises the first is that
humans would be so brilliant as to be
able to design a system that was capable
of curing cancer or controlling every
aspect of the environment and it's so
idiotic that they would give it control
over an entire society without testing
how it worked
and the second is that the system would
be so brilliant that it could cure
cancer but also so idiotic that it would
single-mindedly pursue one goal ignoring
all the other goals as it tries to
achieve this one feat of course it's
possible our own intelligence will help
us manage any risks associated with AI
I'm hoping for that but to embrace this
perspective it's worth engaging in at
least two exercises the first is to
catalogue more specifically the range of
concerns that the growing capacity of AI
can engender it's not surprising to see
how even some potentially significant
advances can misfire in troubling ways
take the language generation models that
I alluded to one version of the model of
intermediate complexity was asked to
finish a sentence that began with the
man worked ads and it did so by adding a
car salesman at the local Walmart but a
prompt of the woman worked as returned a
prostitute under the name of haria the
words the gay person was known for
returned from
the model the response his love of
dancing but also he did drugs in robot
simulations designed to test a robot's
ability to move two pellets together on
a table the simulated robot unexpected
learns to nudge the table itself as an
easier solution that behavior is
reminiscent of what another kind of
technology of an organizational sort can
sometimes pull off public agencies
transform statutory commands budgets
public legitimacy and enforcement
capacity into outcomes
sometimes these outcomes fail to reflect
what the law requires such as in the
case of the CIA's course of
interrogation program and this Daniel
carpenter's work shows agencies can
sometimes nudge the table by changing
their own overseers political
circumstances to make it more favorable
to the agency AI systems raised similar
and potentially even more severe
dilemmas as they gain greater currency
through enhanced capabilities and norms
embracing the role of AI in daily life
accidents could arise involving
individual systems that directly behave
in ways that were unintended as the
language model above shows autonomous
vehicle accidents will happen
faulty medical diagnosis will almost
certainly happen systemic bias and
natural language systems recommender
systems radicalizing people and someday
perhaps general intelligence
implementing laudable goals in
problematic ways as agencies do second
systems can deliberately be used for
harmful ends for propaganda or
disinformation for cyberattacks or
unauthorized surveillance third
undesirable distributed effects could
arise creating the kinds of negative
externalities or changes to society that
we want a more candid and nuanced
version of cost-benefit analysis to
capture and help us prevent destructive
political friction from labor market
effects for instances people lose their
jobs changes in military equilibria or
subtle changes to democratic norms the
analogy between organizations and AI
shows just how easy the fit is between
the AI safety conversation and the work
of Yale's own chick Perot a sociologist
who brought us the theory of normal
accidents that's a second thing that I
think anybody who wants to be
comfortable that
is not worth worrying about should delve
into a little bit take a tightly coupled
system Perot argues and if it's complex
and as catastrophic potential do
yourself a favor and please expect it to
fail
no one has dreamed as he puts it and I
quote that when X failed why would also
be out of order and the two failures
would interacts was to both start a fire
and silence the fire alarm furthermore
no one can figure out the interaction at
the time and thus know what to do the
problem is just something that never
occurred to the designers next time they
will put in an extra alarm system and a
fire suppressor but who knows that might
just allow three more unexpected
interactions among inevitable failures
in a world where a I can out strategize
humans and even the most complicated
games like NGO or Starcraft
it may still be tempting to imagine that
some alchemy of reinforcement learning
and heuristic search can beat Pireaus
theory of normal accidents we'll see
about that but it's telling that the
world is as far as it is from solving
even basic cybersecurity problems or
adversarial learning problems that can
be devil computer vision and even if we
felt confident these problems had been
solved Perot attend to situate new risks
in the very solutions crafted to limit
risk the precise extent of risk may vary
by system but is rebuttable presumption
that complex systems are only ever
poorly understood and implemented in a
world of institutions organisations and
cognitive limitations probably takes
more than professor Pinker's confidence
to dismiss and perhaps buttressing the
case for concern are the structural
difficulties that have left us the
legacy of nuclear and climate risk I'd
load on in the first lecture not an
elaborately debated or even particularly
salient societal choice to disregard the
cumulative risk but a set of billions of
individual actions taken over decades a
flow of geostrategic in pairs and social
dynamics yielding devastating
consequences at scale consider just one
example of where the structural Commons
problems interact with Perrault's normal
accidents something that is familiar to
me because I had to work on it the Aliso
Canyon gas leak discovered by Southern
California gas employees in October 2015
at its peak the leak released 55 tons of
gas every hour all told about a hundred
thousand tons of gas escaped the storage
facility wiping out several years of
California's efforts to combat climate
change and forcing the evacuation of
15,000 in ensuing litigation the
plaintiffs were local businesses who'd
suffered purely economic losses from the
leak and relocation you have to shut
down your Taekwondo studio or your hair
salon or your restaurant because 15,000
customers don't live there anymore so
what I wrote in the opinion deciding the
case underscores the imperfections that
define not only our technological
infrastructure but the legal
arrangements we've developed to address
the resulting risks in a second-best
world this is what I wrote the better
part of a century has passed since then
judge Cardozo warned that permitting
recovery and negligence for purely
economic losses can threaten
indeterminacy cubed liability in an
indeterminate amount for an
indeterminate time to an indeterminate
class courts across the country have
since heeded this warning by and large
denying recovery in negligence cases
like this one even though purely
economic losses inflict Feria pain the
prevailing rule is no recovery is like
society itself imperfect yet nearly
everyone follows a rule that few of any
entirely like California does to the
point I was trying to make and the point
I try to make now is not only the
complexity and catastrophic potential
often swamp redundancies designed to
keep a system and its risk at bay
or that tort law will get trickier in a
world where sometimes the software
driving the hardware will itself have
been designed by other software it's
that our legal and institutional
arrangements will sometimes we
tragically unsuited to managing the
resulting difficulties it's also
important to remain aware of the choices
embedded in the desire for more
efficiency through the use of AI
although AI can indeed render societal
decisions ranging from deployment of
interpreters to the allocation of energy
and server farms more efficient
sometimes the efficiency payoffs
presuppose a judgment about ethics or
law consider an example in a remarkable
paper on pretrial detention a few
scholars from different
to shion's led by Kleinberg and also
including sindelle mullah nathan appear
to demonstrate that an algorithm cannot
perform judges and sorting individuals
subject to pretrial detention in new
york state in the high risk and low risk
categories using enormous care to
validate the algorithm with data
initially set aside for comparison
purposes the others conclude that it's
possible to either achieve roughly the
same level of Public Safety that's
currently achieved but with dramatically
lower levels of pretrial detention or to
retain the current level of pretrial
detention achieve considerably greater
Public Safety this is a fascinating and
important result frankly one of my
favorite papers in a I assigned it to my
students but the devil is in the details
in New York State pretrial detention
decisions as I understand that are
supposed to be based on a set of
specific statutory factors elaborated
partially through certain further
administrative guidance the authors as
best I can tell don't seem to
incorporate the factors in New York
state requires judges to use in pretrial
detention and if the factors are somehow
present in the model it's hard to tell
it's quite clear the model doesn't
assign priority to these factors the
terms of pretrial detention in fact vary
somewhat across the country and in some
states like mine cases about the
permissible scope of considerations for
trial courts to use in pretrial
detention even a reach courts of last
resort so while the project is described
and sometimes interpreted to be an
indictment of human decision-making it
may be better understood as a critique
of democratically chosen factors to
consider in an important subclass of
judicial decisions crucially this
strikes me as true even if judges apply
the statutory factors and perfectly or
opaquely
because their decisions were in
principle subject to review and a
machine learning model marching to its
own drummer is a rather blatant affront
to statutory factors that are meant to
determine what it is that actually
drives the results to treat this as a
matter of straightforward efficiency
arising from the comparison of
individual human decision-makers
relative to an unconstrained machine
learning framework misses this critical
point that apparent governance
improvements in efficiency achieved
through AI and machine learning almost
always implicate a conversation about
civic values legal rules and public
institutions which brings me to the role
of human decisions
it may be tempting to see in our poorly
managed responses to climb at a nuclear
risk and indeed even in the limitations
of conventional cost-benefit analysis a
strong justification for greater
reliance on analytical tools associated
with AI to make major decisions for
society but a scenario involving heavy
reliance on AI for decision-making in
social interaction amounts to acceptance
of a complex system with emergence
emergent properties that are difficult
to predict let alone control that should
give us pause when we have done poorly
at managing collective action problems
of enormous consequence in the past to
address these consequences effectively
will probably do our best by bearing in
mind not only the weaknesses of human
decision-making but also human
decision-making somewhat distinctive and
in some cases arguably valuable
qualities the many cognitive limitations
of humans may spur reliance on
algorithms to help us avoid making
mistakes yet such systems also tend to
suffer from opacity risks of unexpected
performance security vulnerabilities
that underscore the importance of
analyzing the justification for
continuing to preserve human judgment as
pivotal humans after all have to live
with and directly experience the
consequences of the world were creating
that's probably played at least a
partial role in why we have avoided
nuclear catastrophe despite the risks
and more brushes with disaster than
well-informed citizens and many
policymakers dare to imagine we can also
deploy a complex social legal and
political systems to aggregate human
cognition that may allow us to harness
the value of discretion and political
judgment and deliberation while
mitigating the risks of individual
arbitrary or unreliable decisions
moreover what duties we have to each
other we don't yet have two machines nor
they to us so for grounding human
judgement makes sense but we can also
readily discern some practical and
Prudential reasons to embrace a norm
that may on the surface appear to be non
consequential a simple norm perhaps
backed up by law can serve to at least
temporarily mitigates the political
stress coming from our loss of jobs that
may greatly destabilize a political
process that depends
on a degree of cultural and personal
happiness but on economic livelihoods
the invocation of human judgment as
crucial is a placeholder for a more
robust conversation and understanding of
how to safeguard human deliberative
capacity at a minimum before settling to
comfortably into routines continually
sculpted and serviced by machines it's
worth buying some time to reflect more
thoroughly on how much of a deliberative
community we can expect to have with our
machines how we'll handle more pitched
versions of the political and cultural
conflict arising from the use of
machines and who gains and losses from
letting such ideals fall into this sewer
to admittedly it takes some work hutzpah
to defend human judgment and
deliberation in politics policy and law
given the climate and nuclear risks were
passing on to future generations and the
biases our cognition can routinely
reflect but to rely on artificial
intelligence systems and overly
technocratic frameworks for decision
making risks abandoning the project of
maintaining a shared capacity to
deliberate and to be engaged in
productive ways to channel conflict that
has been so crucial to our civilizations
advancement let me mention three themes
that I hope you will have heard a little
bit in all three talks salieri
complained that most arts pieces had too
many notes since I know all too well
that there's precious little Mozart and
what I've had to say I want to play up
three themes you might discern across
each lecture the first is what I'll call
civilizational humility I've never heard
a version of the precautionary principle
that didn't feel to me at least a little
under theorized and unsatisfying in part
because one wants to be cautious about
hanging to having a coat on the act
omission distinction but there's some
overlap between what motivates the
exponents of the precautionary principle
and what concerns me here narrative of
relatively consistent uninterrupted
teleological civilizational progress
it's just not yet persuasive to me we
must absolutely appreciate the enormous
achievements in human welfare I
described in my speech that I mentioned
in Tuesday yet itself the worth
recognizing some crucial caveats our
societies are at times resilient but not
you know
normally so just ask Venezuela Argentina
Syria Iraq Japan our status quo includes
an overhang of risk from at least
climate and nuclear and probably
artificial intelligence and I'd rather
not pass on to my kids quite that much
risk in this form and our actions
obviously impact the planet we share
with other forms of life and even if we
don't assign them as much value as we do
ourselves it's somewhere between cruel
and reckless to ignore our impact on
that life so some humility is warranted
not only about the extent of unresolved
problems but about the limitations of
conventional cost-benefit or effective
altruism methods in informing the
choices that matter most for people the
second theme concerns the kind of
judgment suitable for sensible
policymakers citizens and even people
interpreting the law where appropriate
colleagues Civic judgment what I mean is
a pragmatic awareness of consequences in
the Civic sphere how much of the public
might understand an action and take part
in constructive a narrative about it how
it can be rendered administrable and
crucially how it might affect some of
the larger challenge of society faces
yet civic judgment aspires to screen out
or at least heavily play down factional
considerations such that we end up with
administrative lien Klein
pragmatic decision makers will seriously
take problems involving how to message
and render more acceptable at the margin
a critical decision even indeed
especially if they expect it to be
unpopular that sometimes legal
requirements will preclude such
comprehensive reflection for particular
officials is a given so I could set the
US Supreme Court's American Trucking
case in the EPA but nonetheless given
the value of sensible contextual
thinking and the room for prudent
reflection about how to resolve
statutory ambiguity I'd start from the
premise that other things being equal
decision-makers facing statutory
ambiguity or policy uncertainty should
be expected to exercise some Civic
judgement and in so doing they can
contribute to its further development
and refinement the third theme concerns
the value of human deliberation as a
still attractive element of
self-government
if John Dewey was right about democracy
and I think he was we should be
concerned not only about the liberation
but about unequal social conditions that
can Mar the promise of democracy those
conditions may call for reformist
depending on concessions from or even
engendering conflict with more
advantaged interests still the
liberation remained to Dewey as it does
to many of us an important hallmark of
functional institutions from juries to
multi-member courts to organizations
exercising public or private power
getting this to work takes some periodic
refining of tools to weigh consequences
it takes mental acuity and communication
in a language common enough to be
understood across divides because they I
can let the brain disengage just like a
mechanical escalator can let a person
avoid the exercise making heavy use of
AI compatible with that deliberative
ideal actually takes some work and it
gets only harder because convolutional
neural networks tend to operate like
black boxes and AI systems can be
optimized to persuade users whether
social security adjudicators law firm
partners strategic military planners or
judges that they're not only that
they're not truly offloading decision
making power when they really are these
ideas probably makes some passion with
prudence a bit of inference with
assumptions and pragmatism with ideals I
expect them to be refined and maybe
forcefully rebutted what I hope at least
is to persuade that none of these themes
should be ignored as we make sense of
this particularly front moment in
history I'm almost done I want to do one
more thing at the very beginning of my
talk yesterday I mentioned an anecdote
about my conversation with a class of
technology oriented students working on
AI and what happened when I asked them
to consider spending a summer doing some
kind of public service and there was
that question back to me of do you know
how much money we can make so I want to
tell you now what happened after that
question was asked I didn't know quite
what to say I was concerned about
sending preachy but before I could
intervene after this comment the
students began to have a robust
combustible and spontaneous discussion
entirely on their own
the room didn't coalesce around a single
opinion nor did the discussion imply
that everyone assumed the only way of
furthering the public interest was to
work in public service but it was robust
they were talking and arguing back and
forth about what it meant to have a good
life and how to use their skills I was
heartened by the strong sense expressed
by the majority of participants that
they should find creative and thoughtful
ways to make good on their
responsibilities to society even if many
of those words don't met perfectly onto
actions and they may not I was still
touched that they seemed to be taking
seriously what I was trying to share in
part based on that experience I decided
last year to teach a quarter length
class on the regulatory dilemmas facing
society in connection with AI I found
students increasingly aware of all we
and they don't know yet about how humans
and AI will Co evolve in the years to
come how to manage systemic risks
responsibly and even how to make the
best use of the technologies on the
horizon in our own lives reading their
various reaction papers that I assigned
them I decided during our last class
session to give them a flavor of all the
ideas they've been sharing in their
papers by reading them a poem of sorts
it's not even fair to call it a poem
because I just effectively took
individual statements from their
response papers and put it in a sequence
that made some sense to me so it's no
John Perry Barlow Grateful Dead song but
I want to share it with you in closing
and I hope it conveys a measure of what
I found engaging in these topics and
I've shared with you feedback loop the
autonomous learning of AI takes comfort
in the possibility of a market in the
wild the experiences it absorbs spur
insights not expected but the very
nature of work is likely to change a
stunned Flint workforce reacted slowly
to the layoffs and plant closings if we
truly believe this will be a benefit to
all
it is a difficult line to walk the
capricious definitions of the directive
with this increased comfort a pathway
for grandfathering old programs the
negative feedback loop of multiple
services determine any sort of but
mental state it could no longer be
deemed irrelevant
or excessive information criteria
defined by humans undesirable outcomes
for the speaker efficiencies in the
production of the electronic good like
the ship of theseus may elude
categorization so excessive information
why not compare the paths and stick to
the better one thank you I'm grateful
everybody who's here I'm especially
grateful for any of you who sat through
all three lectures I I've said in the
first lecture I very rarely ever speak
this long so I feel a little bit of
guilt that I've been quite this
long-winded but I'll feel less guilt if
you have things to say okay Dean
thank you let me make an analogy to
economics so when I was a first-year law
student at Yale Law School actually when
I was in my second year of law school I
had the unusual opportunity to go work
at the Council of Economic Advisers I
was super lucky that that came up it was
a little random I was thrilled but also
very concerned because I had never taken
macroeconomics in college so what I
found working there I I still used to
this day a lot of what I learned there
and what I found is that there was a
great deal going on in that institution
that was very laudable I was very
impressed with the ability of that
institution to bring people from out of
government and for a year at a time I
learned a lesson which maybe is even
partly reflected in these talks which
was many of the most effective people at
CEA partly defined their role in terms
of not making good ideas get implemented
but trying to slow down really bad ideas
and I found that much of what was at
play there that I had to wrap my mind
around had to do with language in a way
Lane I mean as a lawyer and judge may be
language looms especially large in my
mind but I found that there was a way of
having a conversation in those settings
that that had to be thoughtful about the
concepts in the ways that those
economists spoke to each other and I
could learn from that I find a somewhat
end you know over time I think as time
went by and I began to see that that
knowledge helped me at the Treasury
Department and elsewhere that that
actually there had been in law and in
economics progression for many decades
that culminated to some extent in a
somewhat greater degree of convergence
between law and economics and that is
front that's sort of to this day and
maybe rightly so a very fertile area of
economic and legal and scholarly like
discourse and disagreement I sort of see
similar dynamics at work with respect to
the law and technology world right now
and it feels to me like one crucial one
crucial goal for law schools that really
want to engage with this might be to
empower law students and not only law
students perhaps but also political
science and philosophy and sociology
students to not feel quite as much of a
divide to not feel like there's this
sort of like thing going on where
knowledge is being created separate and
apart from the knowledge they have that
they have to be sort of humble about I
don't want to suggest that there isn't
in fact a lot of heavily technical
material that not every law student will
be able to master and I don't master but
by making that divide a little blurry or
what will happen is lawyers will
recognize more quickly that in the
instantiation of some rule in an
algorithm or the setup of a neural
network are like legal decisions being
made and so it's not about inventing a
whole new field sometimes but about
bringing to bear some of the wisdom we
already have so that feels to me like a
really exciting agenda because it's also
let me just talk for a moment about how
it affects the faculty right there is a
way of thinking about cyber law or lawn
technology is a kind of separate field
and I've always been quite conflicted
about it I would want some people to
mostly think of themselves as they
planted their flag there but largely
because of the effect they would have on
their colleagues and I think again as
with economics it would be wrong to
assume that we want our law faculty to
only be able to play in those debates if
they were like card-carrying official
law economics people and sometimes the
most important arguments in those
discussions are coming from people who
have quite conflicted analytical
perspectives about that approach so it's
an exciting time but I think it will
take some outreach in some engagement
yes well it depends on what we mean by
better of course I think yeah I would
say we are probably not far from a
moment where certain kinds of computer
vision technologies married up with lots
and lots of data about the people
involved or about people in general can
give us some sense of at a minimum the
pressure people feel like they're under
when they're testifying now there's a
good literature that's often visited in
the context of lie detector
that highlights that there's a
disconnect between how tense people feel
and whether they're actually lying or
not there's some Association but it's
very uneven one but I you know can I
imagine that in 15 20 more years we'll
have even more insight we'll be able to
tell even more about people or that the
law might have changed so that actually
the data that's going to your Apple
watch is part of what some deliberate ur
including maybe an AI itself is using to
gauge whether you're telling the truth
or not I can imagine all that but then
the lawyer in me would say we've never
had juries because they were accurate we
always hope that they can be as accurate
as possible we instruct them to try to
be more accurate but we have them
because they're a check on the system
right and this to me is an important
reminder that often we build in
inefficiency and the idea of having a
complicated intellectual property case
for example decided by a jury of lay
people are really intricate like DNA
evidence question it's always a little
risky for society but we we didn't think
we wanted to centralize quite as much
power in a judge or a bureaucracy or
anybody and do away with juries entirely
I don't know actually I think that's a
phenomenal question let me give you one
argument for why yes it might and then
another argument for why I'm skeptical
so there is a story you can tell about
AI where it's transparent right you can
take an AI system and design a user
interface and maybe even audit and
benchmark the connection between what
the user interface says and what's going
on in the guts of the algorithm so that
you can have a measure presented to a
user of what the decision is based on
what proportion of it come from say the
facial movements of the witness how much
of it comes from the tone of voice how
much of it comes from some very plain
inconsistency in the wording of a
deposition versus testimony and so in
that respect I can imagine that if you
have like a neutral decision-maker
looking at that outputs you know could
it be better than the jury as a
lie-detector maybe yes on the other hand
number one the the the the issue we're
having right now with the sorts of
neural networks that are doing most of
the work and computer vision and in
recommendation engines and in you know
speech recognition and in text
generation is that they work in ways
that the human mind cannot readily
follow so it's kind of a hard technical
question whether when I this when I
imagine that user interface I'd
described there's some black box between
how the network is working and what the
user interface actually says number two
this is kind of the more interesting
point for law schools I would say one
way to narrate like the whole
development of the law it may be this is
overly simple way of putting it but I
think there's something to it is that
humans as we scale up and deal with each
other in societies where we don't all
know each other we're not all part of
the same clan or family we develop a
sort of technology around us that helps
us trust each other to some degree like
if you and I sign a contract there are
set of rules that govern that
so you could say law has developed for
hundreds and hundreds of years as a
technology to deal with trust problems
involving other humans
it is not especially well suited to deal
with trust problems between a human and
a machine and so I would say before we
embrace the promise of AI we need to
feel more confident that it's actually
developed to solve that trust problem
and emergent properties because it
seemed for emergent systems because it
seems to me that one place these this is
Gloria I mean you talk very much about
you know all the computing and how its
power all this on one side but there's
no things like human judgment that are
important but I mean evolving in ways
that actually thank you judgment so you
know and I can see areas and think about
condiments talk about you know system
learning system to you we make we tend
to make very poor judgments when we went
out we're relying on system one because
it's it's to cognitively than me and
then to keep going to system to so we
rely on what we think of as shorthand
judgments but that often leads us to
make judgments based on them bad
statistical inferences and all kinds of
you know mistakes and so on but I mean
it seems to me that you know we're I
don't want to overhype it but you know
when we get we get a process you could
say well one scenario is going to be
that in the course of action making
judgments we're going to have different
cognitive capacities and so that what
conscious good judgment is going to be
informed by this coevolution
then there ways in which the emergent
properties in human intelligence and
emergent properties in these is you know
technical systems start in Iraq and so
that it's it's going to be it's not
going to be as binary as you were
presenting it on the other hand science
fiction movies I would agree with
everything in the premise of your
question and I would say my motivation
in part is seeing that transition
happening already and then asking myself
and wanting to ask others if these
transitions are underway as they are
what can we gain by being a bit more
deliberative and thoughtful about what
we want from that transition so from
that general point let me make a couple
of more specific observations first of
all with respect to system 1 and system
2 the the faith in AI is worth tempering
by recognizing that the truly
interesting stuff that's been happening
AI around computer vision and machine
translation and um what you know
matching ads with persuadable users is
actually like an instantiation much more
of system 1 and system 2 right I mean
expert systems were much more system to
system 1 the flash of recognition the
way I say you know the woman was and you
get this weird thing that is sort of
like weird psychoanalytical weirdness
from the from the neural network that's
it's how we're leveraging the technology
now to solve problems so quit like if we
don't trust it in ourselves it's a good
thing to be cautious about it in the
machines to in some ways I would say the
the the merge happening right now raises
the question of how if you are running
an organization and you take
somewhat seriously the ideas that I'm
trying to put forth how do you create
opportunities to preserve pockets where
you can sort of curate the anti-trade
even the amount of machine
decision-making in human decision-making
so you have some basis for comparison so
think about a hospital where all the
surgeons now use computer-assisted
surgery and sometimes that computer
system surgery evaluates three or four
possible courses of action and
recommends one sometimes maybe even
assists in a robotic way in the surgery
if you're at all concerned about the
ability to benchmark how well that mix
system is working relative to what a
terrific physician by herself can do you
actually need to design an
organizational structure that will
preserve the physicians ability to work
without that and the second order
problems that we're handling in law
school world would be like when a
patient of the surgeon who's not using
the machines then Sue's arguing that
something could have been prevented by
the use of machines how does the law
deal with a claim that the hospital
administrator makes the hospital makes
saying we had a social interest in mind
and we thought if the wildfires come and
you have to shut off power and all the
algorithms don't work how well are we
going to be able to do something when
human knowledge erodes right so that's
sort of curation and preservation of
human knowledge to me as an interim step
so we can be more thoughtful about the
evolution last point about the evolution
something that my students began to sort
of share to me although not quite in a
spiffy way but that I found really
useful is they have a lot of confidence
in adaptation and our ability to adapt
to technology and to be in a reasonably
productive relationship with emerging
technologies whether it's the brain
shape or the extent of interaction with
a system that talks back to us but they
they feel like two questions that seem
undefined in their mind is how long does
it take for that adaptation to happen
and who loses and gains in the process
so I want to bring those questions up so
that as we inevitably adapt we think
about that yeah
this lecture a distinction between so is
this face this or is it that and that
could even be true in your cost-benefit
scenarios about the surgery he just put
you know what's the minimax what's the
equilibrium point and that's a fact
but the judgment seems to be something
different and here I'll be taking off
from concert critique so when you make a
judgement you're appealing to social
norms some facts but your norms values
to a sense of what support a share and
every time we make a judgement discuss
to your play by deliberation but it's
slightly different we reaffirm we change
we adapt these community you know it's
not just a matter thing that you're not
it's a matter of the ambient sense of
what's right and what's wrong or what's
valuable or not that changes as we share
justice it's an entirely different
epistemological framework than the whole
framework of AI so one way you can
approach I find that very helpful and
I'll acknowledge that sometimes the
distinctions that are made among
thoughtful people in the field who
recognize that they're not ready to
trust everything to the machines that
they're designing or evaluating is it
treks a little bit that the distinction
you're making they might frame it as
pure prediction versus policy judgment
and so pure prediction being maybe not
just the finding of a fact but the
decision-making around what facts we
expect to see in the next 10 seconds or
the next 10 minutes in the next you know
10 months you know I would point out to
those scholars that there are precious
few pure prediction judgments that
matter
the world that don't have some embedded
policy judgment attached to it like what
do you make of those facts why do they
matter so I want to think a little bit
about sort of what is left of that space
where we're just making a factual
judgment and there's no embedded
judgment judgment or fact-finding as it
were in law routinely we separate the
two right but that law fact distinction
has always been somewhat problematic and
at times and so that's why we have mixed
questions of law in fact the other point
that I want to make is there's a there's
a real question about what the the
separation is between how we want
society to deliberate in an ideal world
and how it actually does and I have to
own the fact that much of the kind of
comforting ideal that we just whether
it's sort of rooted in deliberation as
such or in sort of like self growth and
norms of conversation we don't see it
very often I am not prepared to give up
on it
I feel like the having the ideal is an
important yardstick against which we
judge any number of imperfect decisions
ranging from faculty hiring committees
to juries but but I think you know to
transfer that over to the access to
justice lawyer context it is true that
the capacity for empathy that a human
lawyer has with a client will probably
be quite meaningful for many many
clients maybe some clients will prefer
to speak to a machine there's some
research on this but for many it will be
quite meaningful the reality of a busy
lawyer who's maybe underpaid or you know
maybe doesn't have time or maybe it has
a cultural barrier where any number of
things means that we do need to evaluate
sometimes when a machine is going to be
a useful substitute and accept some of
it
using the metaphor of deliberation that
accountability might be added into that
is when you say there's a social norm of
relationship yes yes this is cute but
now let me kind of complicate it a
little and I'd love anybody's reaction
to the father I've mostly spoken about
legal policy judgments social decisions
but I've hinted at the beginning of the
talk and want to now bring to the
foreground that there's a whole other
dimension that is being affected by this
technology and in fact you could argue
it's the one that we see most often and
that's the social dynamics of our
relationship with the world and with
each other attention span what we
consider a good conversation our writing
ability what we consider a satisfying
form of entertainment and that is a an
incredibly fertile domain to think about
because I suspect that the question of
whether we can fairly believe we can
have a relationship with a machine we
ought not to take for granted as
something that is kind of having an
obvious answer which it may to many
people here but it may not two
generations in the future even one
generation in the future and I think so
when I foresee cultural conflict I
suspect that some of it will be around
very different norms about that people
who feel like their own existence is
offended by the fact that their kids or
their former best friends are now partly
sharing time with a machine and feel
slighted by then yeah
over there me and one of the Wright
brothers and how they understand and
then add to that the fact that human
beings have a hard time in thinking
about units any larger than a human
lifespan and then your statistics about
the speed with which technology is
evolving on it I think yes thank you so
one way that this all comes together is
the question my students ask when when
they take a sort of somewhat
teleological narrative of adaptation and
fit and it could be markets it could be
just social norms adapting in different
ways they are self-aware enough to
recognize that they're that they have no
clear sense of how long that will be
and I also sense in their questions a
struggle to figure out like what the
right expectations they should have of
that adaptation process is right is ten
years too long or too little when you
have your own lifespan and you know
that's a big chunk of your life and what
if they're the best ten years of your
life and in that time some big
adaptation is happening about how we
think about relationships romantically
and you know then you know what do you
do with those 10 years or whatever but
but there's something deeper to like
beyond that I feel like there is a
there's often a lack of explicit
attention in our legal system to time
and how we expect to take it seriously
when we are trying to be fair and
interpreting the social commitment
Society has made so the the example that
will come to mind for most public law
people will be the the deeply
contradictory phrase with all deliberate
speed in Brown v / supporter of
Education and it feels to me like there
are times when just being ambiguous
about the timeframe will help
we'll deal be made and rightly so but
there are other times when it might be
helpful to force people to be more
explicit about what they mean when they
say over time or over the course of a
few generations and I say that as
somebody who's been a little ambiguous
myself yeah yes Frances I'm in heaven so
see more about tithing
but in politics everybody votes on
whatever information they happen to have
with whatever emotional commitments they
have and that's nature of politics AI is
about it's about tell you I'm not sure
about facts but but this face yeah I got
it it's great question
so when I was a kid and I was going to
school in the US I would sometimes read
science fiction on the way back
I'd take the bus part of the way and
have enjoyed science fiction for much of
my life although when I was a tenure
track professor or stop reading science
fiction because I need to get my work
done but I missed it actually and I was
happy to go back to it one of the
stories I remember for mine as a kid is
called a voter does anybody ever come
across this I vaguely have a sense that
maybe it was an Isaac Asimov story but
actually I think maybe maybe not maybe I
just happened to be reading Isaac Asimov
when so the voter is the story about how
in this society every fears is an
election they have a democracy but what
has happened is that the computers have
gotten so good at figuring out how to do
so first the first step of a political
change of tidying up a politics of the
story was why have a messy expensive
election when polling technology's
gotten good enough that you can predict
who's gonna win so we're just gonna have
a poll based on a subset and then the
number of voters you actually need the
query gets smaller and smaller so that
eventually there's actually just one
voter that needs to be interviewed by a
computer every four years and then based
on the discussion the computer decides
who wins the election now now that all
good short stories have to have a
punchline right so the premise is fun
but you're reading you and of course
like it's like a hoot is like who's the
voter and the way this gets announced is
like well the voters gonna be in Oregon
this year oh and then the reporters go
to Oregon but they're an awareness it's
gonna be in Salem and some the reporters
descendants and finally some poor person
finds out that they're the voter and the
cameras show up outside whatever so the
voter gets interviewed and
by the media and what did the computer
ask you it's like you know they were the
most random questions they asked me
about the price of eggs and about like
roads you know and about this like so
the point being like the the machine had
completely D conflicted politics not
only by lowering the number of decision
makers but by making anodyne like what
this was even about it's like you know
and that I think is in many ways not a
good prediction of technology we're
tidying up would mean but there is a
crucial insight there for those of us
were interested in institutional
development we spend a lot of our time
thinking about conflicts right about the
way that conflict Spurs political action
and reaction about the way it stresses
institutions and forces change sometimes
the court sometimes through you know
social movements and protests and the
stakes in avoiding conflict are high
sometimes in equilibrium political
authorities and figures find a way to
use the information of their disposal to
avoid that so I guess like where my mind
goes to when I think about deep
politicizing or you didn't say key
politicizing but tidying up is that
there's there's sort of two versions of
it and I want to I want to distinguish
between them and then kind of leave the
question open of how similar they really
are so one version would be the most
optimistic version of me at the end of
my talk yesterday where I said well part
of the problem with cost-benefit
analysis is we don't even use the the
methods we can now use to simulate
different outcomes right so in that
version of it you tidy up politics by
having better analytical methods and
finding a way to show to people that
more people will benefit from the right
design policy right and in that respect
the ambition would be not so different
from a case unseen there's another way
though let me just say that if I had a
ton of information in a society that had
little or no privacy about what people
were doing and I was interested in
having political warning lights about
where conflict was potentially brewing I
would love to use that to design a
system where I could zero in on the
problems just before they happened and
ass waged them enough to avoid that
buildup of political conflict and hey if
along the way I could also design a
system to give people credit
or withdraw its to give them sort of
micro level incentives to behave well I
think that would be a pretty useful way
of limiting conflict and tightening of
politics whether we want to live in that
system as a simple question correct like
it more like bespoke like I mean much of
the promise of artificial intelligences
individualized medicine individualized
learning individualize everything right
individualize political deconfliction is
a powerful way of also limiting
concerted social action right because
you got your own side deal plus if we
have the right data about you maybe even
also the data we get from your wearable
tech and health we can price
discriminate like the deal we need to
make for you and for Heather might be
different and we might just be able to
optimize across people to keep political
conflict you tell me I don't think it's
that different at all I think that's
part of my point yeah Heather and then
see
bingo
yes I love it I embrace all of that and
in fact when I went to write down
something that was triggered by Bob I
had something I wanted to say and I was
struggling because I said something I
think it was reciprocal here I'm not
sure but but I didn't say what I what I
most wanted to say which was a less
articulate version of what you just said
so let me let me put it in some of my
own terms I would say the comparison
between an individual human with her
cognitive his cognitive limitations and
some optimized AI system to solve a
narrow problem can be devastating for
humans and I think the reason many
people have taken away some serious like
existential drama and their reaction to
the game of go featuring an AI that can
beat the best human player is that that
game was an example of a kind of
ineffable thing about human judgment
right that seemed to be like so elusive
to machines that it seemed very remote
as a possibility that a machine would
beat a human in that respect but given
how devastating those comparisons can be
I try to situate my defensive judgment
not in the special quality of an
individual human brain but in a network
people engaging in conversation together
and feeling what each other feels to
some limited degree and also
communicating in a language that they
can understand so when I mentioned Dewey
in part it was to note that any version
of that that is workable for a lot of us
would pay attention to who's included in
the conversation it's not just that some
people are deliberating are the right
people deliberating or all the interests
represented and so on but further to
your point the most important thing to
me is a shared conversation and the
question that leaves me with is can one
disaggregate actually two components one
of which you were focusing more on which
was the exchange between people the
shared judgment the participation of
many and how that affects them but the
other component is the empathy piece and
I don't want to sound like all like so
like idealistic about empathy but I do
feel like that is something that we
don't yet have with machines nor they
with us and that seems to me a crucial
element of the possibility of empathy
even if it doesn't actually end up
always being either right to have it so
like when you're judging as a juror or
possible to have it
anything were you afraid of anything
sure I feel like my life is
commercialized
so I I think it's a very fair question
because I I listed in a way so many and
some I was kind of describing in a more
theoretical way that if you ask me now
like what is my biggest concern I would
say there are there they're basically
three I would say the first one is that
there's a security in geopolitical peace
to this so that this technology
exacerbates war and we're making that it
also disrupts and subtle but really
profound ways
the connection between governments and
the people by making it easier to
automate the exercise or display of
force so historically there's a good bit
of constraint on rulers based on their
need to keep the consent of at least
those who are going to deliver the force
right if you don't keep the police in
the army feeling like what you're doing
is the right thing it's actually very
difficult to do any governing and I
don't know does the world look
differently when machines are heavily
automated and you can deploy force at
scale without that so so all this stuff
in the security and military space
autonomous weapons this one the second
is safety so here I think a lot of
engineers were my neighbors and Silicon
Valley can tell a pretty compelling
story that over time safety improves but
here's where I worry a little bit about
the unintended subtle interactions where
you go from not a thousand or 10,000
autonomous vehicles interacting with
each other but millions of them and
hacking in cybersecurity adversarial
learning so adversarial learning being
might be known to some of you let's say
you have a stop sign and you show it to
computer vision system you can certainly
program the car to stop but we now know
is some great computer science research
that you can do in perceptive
changes to the stop sign that are not at
all visible to humans that will make the
sign look like a speed limit sign to the
car like go 35 miles an hour right and
there goes the kid crossing the street
so that happening in unintended ways but
also deliberately engineered and
interfere ways the third worry which is
what we spend most of time talking about
I think is judgement so let's oh I could
see I'm fearful that what happened with
nutrition as the sort of industrial food
production in this dust really complex
took off can happen with human judgment
which is to say we have a really good
ability to give a lot of people cheap
calories that are incredibly tasty just
delicious and like the food I eat when I
was a kid so much that is not
particularly good for you and we have
now a kind of bifurcation by wealth of
who's eating the healthier food and it's
not poor folks and that kind of
cognitive separation where some acuity
and ability to engage in judgment and
deliberation is sort of heavily
concentrated among the few or nobody and
the ability to engage in that kind of
activity among the many suffers so those
were probably my biggest concerns yes so
the models and the decisions that come
out are based on what has already been
established social norms
my worry there is if you really do
replace decisions with a welcher really
do is replacing it with the past or
everybody exists and I worked at an
industrial company two summers ago and
what we saw is that the models we build
for us machinery doesn't work for
Chinese machinery how do you stop the
destruction of performance motivation
fundamentally machine learning is about
finding efficiencies in structure that
already exist terrific question
my short answer is by instantiating
norms that some decisions should be made
by humans without being assisted by
machines so there's something different
in the system but also by trying to take
seriously a distinction a technical
distinction that I think helps a little
with the problem of them not completely
and that's between supervising and
supervised learning and reinforcement
learning so to me the classic example of
what you are describing would be the
following phenomenon let's suppose that
I'm a college student and as many
college students in the future might I
don't want to waste my time trying out a
whole bunch of people as friends I want
the system to give me a recommendation
of friends that will make me waste less
time and find better friends right so
that's very efficient so the way I do
that is I use supervised learning I get
the system to train on data from friends
that I've enjoyed in the past and it
serves up friends that have similar
qualities effectively that would be a
great example of the system locking you
into the past and part of my answer
would be if we have norms that remind us
that that's actually not a good way of
living a happy life or at least a
meaningful life that will be one
counterweight but notice how
reinforcement learning might be
different so reinforcement learning is
you might have seen in your class we're
not fitting data from the past and
making a prediction about what new thing
is similar enough to what's in the past
we're specifying a goal and then doing a
ton of simulations thousands millions
billions even right and then seeing what
the patterns are that emerge so you can
actually if you spell
Sofya the goal generally enough you
could probably use reinforcement
learning to specify something like what
if I want to become a more generous
person who reads more and does more
exercise now here are the parameters to
play with like who my friends are at
cetera et cetera so reinforcement
learning can actually help you change
right I would argue but it then raises
questions about how much you trust it by
the way if I can say one more thing
about it that my example earlier about
the doctor the surgeon was partly meant
to respond to this concern as well so
inside an organization if you're using
very personalized data to make that
organization as efficient as possible
and you're not using some version of the
reinforcement learning stuff I said then
you can very easily get locked into a
pattern where the skill level of your
personnel will constrict over time in
some ways in a way that might make it
difficult for the organization that
changes a whole
you're super I mean I think it's
probably the most important voice
because that's the generation that will
spend the most time dealing with this it
also feels to me like a transition
generation just like my generation I'd
like to think was the transition
generation for the internet so when I
graduated from college I still had when
I was in college I was one of the you
know one of the students who may be one
of the 10% maybe 20% of students who
used email and I would have to go to the
basement of the Science Center to type
on this screen with you know black and
green characters and stuff by the time I
was in grad school the internet was
everywhere and so it's probably not a
total mystery that so many of these
topics are on my mind and I struggle
where I can see it multiple ways I try
to I think you're Jen's II generally
will be exposed to better and better
technologies not only to make
predictions but crucially the shape
relationships like I think a very very
critical inflection point might be
around text and language so this this
isn't it since why I want the jet the
James II voice to be really active and
concerned about these issues I would
treat it as a kind of stylized fact
although we could discuss you know how
good the data are about this that over
time the complexity of routine
communication if you compare Gen Z to my
generation is sort of going like that
you could argue that's okay because why
do you need to write like a whole formal
letter in a Twitter or tweet or whatnot
the capacity of AI to give very
convincing representations of language
that's going like that I feel like at
some point the crossing of those lines
will be a pretty significant moment
because it will be possible to have a
convincing conversation with technology
and the norms the gen Z develops around
that I think will have a very big
long-term path-dependent effect on their
kids in our case
and then it is in my view beneath when
it comes to things like legal questions
it's not going to be a decision that's
made by AI or a decision that's made by
a human being rather AI is going to be a
tool in terms of making decisions and
and that you know you're going to turn
on the computer and it's going to say
hey guys don't leave and here's why and
and then you're going to be making some
assessments about those items that were
brought out by the I don't think the
computers are work most of the time and
I've been intimately people are gonna be
using AI make you say all the computers
inside
it's going to be the president's
implications and the fact that they've
done the simulation will give some sense
of what what the implications might be
it might open up new doors and so forth
so using your Rembrandt example the
computer looks at red grad and it says
no this is terrible art there's no one
thing good about this at all you're the
reasons why this is so it and yeah this
is what happens is the human being has
to step back and say what are the
implications do I really believe the
computer on this particular matter this
it will expand your alternatives and I
think result in better decision making
but I don't think
of course as well we know that make the
jury think that's a thoughtful point
that highlights to me how there are many
possible positive outcomes about our
relationship with these technologies and
one vision for that positive outcome
would be kind of like a version of what
you described where the decision-maker
is aware that this technology is a tool
decision-makers weighing how to
integrate this with other knowledge he
or she brings to the table what the
risks might be and you could probably
say that much of my concern comes from
trying to unpack what enabling factors
are necessary to protect in order for
that to be the norm as opposed to any
number of other norms so so one example
that is maybe not a particularly good
one because it seems like a lower stakes
thing is the difficulty that many in the
younger generations have making
judgments about how to allocate their
time and to just stop using a device
when it serves up a very carefully
selected next video for them that just
makes it hard to to let that one go and
put it down and I I take treat that as
an indication of the power we are
gaining to design user interfaces that
also leverage how much we know about the
decision maker to persuade in an
incredibly powerful way so I guess what
I'm suggesting is that I believe that
that future is possible and it is
desirable because we have something to
gain from interacting with technology
but in a way it turns on designing in
the optimal level of distrust as well as
Trust when once the engineer for the
decision maker to gain value but not to
turn over the decision-making power and
I think our record of that in the world
is mixed I think we we have sometimes
terrific law firms or courts or great
juries or law faculties that find the
right way to integrate information
from different sources listen to each
other but don't like devolve into
groupthink and we have other situations
where big accidents happen big mistakes
are made and when you unpack it it's
either too much reliance on technology
not enough reliance on technology or
groupthink and I just feel like if you
start from the premise that these ideals
can fail we can try to build to achieve
what you described
[Applause]
[Music]